[Music]
while there's a fun day also you work
with Bill Paxton and he passed away
today and I think it was shocking to all
but your thoughts on bill
friend Thank You chart and Josh reminded
me a few things this morning when I
frankly didn't want to come tonight
Oh wrong somehow josh says he loved
everything Hollywood mr. everything
Hollywood tradition so furious at me my
just come celebrate and also I could
hold me a piece of his big heart and
somewhere in all the characters even his
villain and so to hang out with him the
cub wanted movies into the beauty
players hang out with them and I can do
that whenever I need that bill hang it
was such big love with such a great show
rules are like working together and
being on a show like that it was did
everyone seemed to love crazy is that
that was the show devoid of drama for a
so so full of conflict and story we
would have done it for 40 years I mean
everyone loved each other there was so
much before there was so much on expect
and there's so much fun in fact I think
probably we may sit that this was back
on Clintonville people shot on film and
we wasted a lot of it googling so it was
just it was a dream job I never wanted
to leave we had to shut down Coffee
hours the day when I was it we weren't
coming back because the camera guys were
crying the cameras up shaking they were
like go to dinner you know call your
family no one ever wanted to leave
you